a babysitter who killed a child she was
watching is heading to prison thank you
for joining us at six I'm Kirsten Joyce
I'm Brian Loftus this is a story the 8
news now investigators first broke have
been following closely Vanessa Murphy
was the only TV Camera in court today
for what was an emotional sentencing we
do want to warn you this story is of a
sensitive nature
Lauren Courtney sentenced to life in
prison with the possibility of parole
after 20 years she was babysitting a
child when she was caught on camera
beating him to death the judge noting
the brutality of the case and how
five-year-old Ryan peralto suffered in
his last moments the last minutes of
that child's life
or a pure horror Lauren Courtney
learning her fate Wednesday after
pleading guilty to first-degree murder
anybody who watches
Courtney asking Ryan peraltos family for
forgiveness
I could do more than just use my words
prosecutor Michelle Jobe remembering
Ryan it is very very clear that Ryan was
a happy five-year-old child and then
describing Courtney's actions which
ended his life she drives him around the
house when he's vomiting blood she is
yelling at him screaming a hen
about her it's her bad day it's her
situation that he's upsetting her that
day Joby calling a claim from Courtney's
defense that she could have been
sleepwalking as offensive and repeatedly
noting the brutality of the crime she
then left him on the couch for
approximately an hour hour and a half
dying because she wouldn't do anything
to get him Medical Care Clark County
District Court Judge Jacqueline Bluth
acknowledging how emotional this
sentencing is before sending Courtney to
prison for life
a five-year-old
understands every blow every punch every
stop every slap when you're screaming
vitriolic hate in their face
they know what's happening to them for
26 Long minutes Ryan knew what you were
doing to him the child's parents not
present in the courtroom due to the
trauma Joby reading a statement from
Ryan's dad describing how his sister who
was seven at the time is trying to cope
why did her brother have to go away to
heaven
the only time that Carly gets to see her
brother now is when she dreams of him in
her sleep of their happy memories
together
no amount of healing can fill the whole
of sadness that Lauren left us with
Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now
the prosecutor saying that the home
surveillance camera was just activated
that morning after Ryan's sister said
Courtney may have hurt Ryan previously
but they had no definitive proof and
didn't want to falsely accuse her it
turns out when Courtney was confronted
by police she tried blaming Ryan's dad
but that video showed otherwise